talking of scams
households are going to have to fork out
an extra 19 billion pounds on their
energy bills
the government is insulting people's
intelligence by pretending it's giving
them a discount
but it's not
it's a con
a buy now pay later scheme a dodgy loan
not a proper plan
mr speaker
he shakes his head so let me put this in
language you might understand
when his donors give him cash to fund
his lifestyle and tell him he has to pay
it all back later are they giving him a
loan or a discount
[Applause]
mr speaker up
our plan
our plan to tackle the cost of living is
faster more efficient and more generous
than anything uh that they have set
up we've lifted we've lifted the living
wage by record amounts uh we've cut the
we've cut the effective tax for people
on universal credit mr speaker and we're
now setting out a fantastic plan to help
people with the cost of energy mr
speaker and and it is it is more
generous and more effective than more
generous and more effective than
anything labor have set out and the only
reason we can do it's 9.1 billion pounds
mr speaker it's huge sums that we're
using to help people across the country
and the only reason we can afford it mr
speaker is because we have a strong
economy the fastest growing in the g7 as
i think i may have pointed out
to the on to the right of honourable
last week
not just last year but this year as well
mr speaker the prime minister clearly
hasn't got the first clue what the
chancellor's signed him up to
so let me help him out his plan is to
hand billions of pounds of taxpayers
cash to energy companies
and then force families to pay it off in
installments for years to come
if it if it sounds like he's forcing
people to take out a loan
and it looks like he's forcing people to
take out a loom isn't it just forcing
people to take out a loan
we are giving people in uh in band d
council attack a to d transplants can't
attack houses council tax valuations
across the country that is 27 million
homes we're giving them the equivalent
of 150 pound rebate off their counter
their offer is for 89 pounds mr speaker
ours is faster more generous and more
effective and what what they would do
what they would do and you know this is
a global problem mr speaker caused by
the spiking caused by the spike in gas
prices but what they would do is clobber
the the oil and gas companies right now
uh where they yes
with a tax with a tax that would deter
investment in gas just when this country
needs gas mr speaker as we transition to
green fuel it would be totally
ridiculous and it would raise prices for
consumers
mr speaker i was always worried that the
prime minister wasn't one for reading
terms and conditions
he didn't understand what the chancellor
signed him up to and he's just confirmed
my worst fears
there is an alternative
but order order can i just say if you
want to carry on carry on outside i am
not having this perpetual noise coming
from the front bench secretary of state
should know better and i expect better
and i certainly don't need to put up
with it anymore kirsten
[Music]
mr speaker there is an alternative he
could stand up to his chancellor tell
him to support families rather than
loading them with debt tell him to look
at those bumper profits of oil and gas
giants shells profits up 14 billion
pounds this year bp's profits up 9.5
billion pounds this year
mr speaker every second of the day
they've made 750 pounds extra profit
from rising prices at the same time
households are facing an extra 700
pounds a year on their bills
why on earth
is this government forcing loans on
british families when they should be
asking those with an unexpected windfall
to pay a little more to keep household
bills down
the labor plan would clobber supplies
it's an improvement on what do you i
thought he stood for which was
nationalizing the energy companies maybe
maybe he's maybe he's dropped that one
now i can't tell whether he's dropped
that one or not but mr speaker what he
would be doing maybe he has what he
would be doing mr speaker is hitting the
energy companies at precisely the moment
when we need to encourage them to go for
more gas mr speaker because we need to
transition now to cleaner fuels and what
this government is providing is 9.1
billion pounds worth of support it's
more generous than anything labor is
offering and i just repeat my point the
only reason we can do it is because we
kept our economy moving in those hard
times when they took the wrong decisions
and we we came out of lockdown in july
mr speaker when he opposed it last year
and we kept going over christmas and new
year when they opposed it mr speaker and
that's why we have the fastest growing
economy in the g7 not just last year but
this year as well as i never tire i'm
saying
he can bluff and bluster all he likes
the reality is this
on top of the tory tax rises on top of
the soaring prices the loan shark
chancellor and his unwitting sidekick
have now picked up a buy now pay later
scheme
it leaves taxpayers in debt
while oil and gas companies say they've
got more money than they know what to do
with
it's the same old story with this
government get in a mess protect their
mates and ask working people to pick up
the bill
[Music]
but isn't he worried that everyone can
now see that with this prime minister
and this chancellor it's all one big
scam and people across the country are
paying a price
mr speaker what they can see is a
government that is absolutely committed
to doing the right thing for the people
of this country and and taking the
taking the tough decisions when labor is
calling for us to take the easy way out
and spend more taxpayers money and mr
speaker it was it was this government
that decided to keep going in july uh
when he wanted uh to stay in lockdown we
kept going over christmas and you and by
the way mr speaker it occurs to me uh
that we also were able to use those
brexit freedoms to deliver the fastest
foods to work and the fastest facts he
wrote yes mr speaker when he not only
voted 48 times 48 times to go back into
the eu yes he did but he also voted to
stay in the european mentions agency mr
speaker
our plan our plan for jobs is working mr
speaker
we have record low youth unemployment
our plan for the nhs and care is working
mr speaker they have no plan at all mr
speaker our plan for the country is
working we have a great vision mr
speaker to unite and level up across our
country they have no plan whatever mr
speaker and i say to him plan beats no
plan we have a great plan for our
country they play politics